[Music]
on this Wednesday night preparing for a
surge in patients new hospitals old
facilities being repurposed why the next
two weeks will be critical for Canada
new details on the federal wage subsidy
which businesses are eligible when
they'll get help and who is still
waiting mounting tales of heartbreak
died alone we didn't even get to say
behind plus toughening measures across
the US an evolving debate isn't worth
wearing a face mask in public and the
detective work of contact tracing it is
vital plus Canadian researchers racing
to find treatments
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
more time language is now being used to
describe the fight against kovat 19 an
invisible enemy that has changed all our
lives Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
calls it the greatest economic and
health challenge since the Second World
War and the emergency aid plan being
rolled out for individuals and
businesses is the largest in Canadian
history the Prime Minister says it is
the duty of every Canadian to do their
part listening to public health rules is
your duty staying home is your way to
serve there are new details about those
71 billion dollar wage subsidy to help
businesses keep employees on the payroll
we'll get to that in just a moment but
first the numbers that everyone is
watching there are now close to 1
million people around the world who are
known to have the virus 70,000 new cases
today alone here in Canada nearly 10,000
people have now tested positive that's
an increase of more than 1,100 over
yesterday several provinces saw a steep
rise in new cases today Ontario reported
426 positive tests that's double the
number of new cases reported yesterday
Manitoba had 24 new cases that is more
than triple the previous day and Quebec
had 449 new cases that's a big number
but it's actually down quite a bit from
yesterday when the province confirmed
732 new cases its highest single day
total those numbers don't paint the full
picture we know not everyone with
symptoms is being tested we know there's
a backlog of tests and there's a lag
time in getting results and just because
you haven't heard about cases in your
community does not mean they don't exist
April promises a new wave of infections
and as Eric Sorenson reports new
facilities are already being built for
the coming surge it's an ominous sight
urgent construction of an instant
addition to the Joseph Brant Hospital in
Burlington west of Toronto it will house
more than 90 new beds for a surge of
kovat 19 patients expected soon
so far many cases in the country have
occurred in clusters in Calgary for
residents of the McKenzie
town continuing care center have died
there and across the country outbreaks
have revealed the vulnerability of
seniors homes even family must stay away
it's sad says Quebec premier but it's a
question of life and death in Keystone
view and MA but so far Canada as a whole
has fared well for the month of March
the single biggest surge was in Quebec
about a week ago when the numbers shot
up towards 4,000 that's largely
explained by travelers coming back after
the early March break and other trips
now Ontario also began to surge up
towards 2000 not as many as you might
expect for the biggest province but then
Ontario has lagged behind in testing for
BC and Alberta they did a lot of early
testing and their numbers have flattened
out ever so slightly a hopeful sign now
we bring those 4,000 number down to 200
and that's where the other provinces are
below that number Saskatchewan has the
highest number but then Saskatchewan did
a lot of testing for the rest of those
provinces a steady rise for Nova Scotia
Manitoba New Brunswick even Pei
the one that stands out here is
Newfoundland and Labrador it is a
smaller province but it has the highest
per capita number of cases in any
province except for Quebec and then
finally the northern territories and
luckily up in the north the numbers are
still relatively low but say experts
April will test our resolve as a country
we're now in the thick of it and this is
going to be going on for several weeks
the virus is spreading an outbreak among
temporary foreign workers at bailan
nurseries in West Kelowna BC 14 tested
positive initially they're exempt from
travel restrictions deemed essential
workers in Canadian agriculture tightly
placed together for sleeping purposes
for accommodations then new facilities
are being built or repurposed the
Convention Center in Vancouver the
former hotel dieu hospital in Montreal
and the rush to put up that new field
hospital in Burlington Ontario
facilities that may be needed as soon as
they're ready
Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto part
of the pandemic planning is what happens
when it's over and how businesses that
are on life support now can bounce back
to full production quickly that's what
the federal wage subsidy is supposed to
do businesses are desperate for details
on how it will work and today we got
some our chief political correspondent
David akin is taking us through them
David well Donna in its basic conception
the Canada emergency wage subsidy sounds
pretty straightforward is it it's going
to be available for businesses big and
small that are not publicly funded and
have seen a 30% or more decline in gross
revenues that includes everything from
bars and restaurants to charities and
nonprofits but then there's the details
the biggest one when will this wage
subsidy be paid answer it will take
three to six weeks businesses will get
this subsidy from the Canada Revenue
Agency and will have to show that their
monthly revenue this year drop by at
least thirty percent compared to the
same period last year but what about
those businesses that cannot make that
comparison a start-up for instance that
might have just started earning revenue
this year or a business that might
operate on such thin profit margins that
loss of revenue of even 5% could mean
collapse for businesses just started up
in the last year we're working on how to
to deal with that one way would be that
they show us the previous month's
revenue and show that the decline has
happened but we will have details on on
that situation in other situations in
the coming days the cost of this wage
subsidy program will also be huge an
estimated 71 billion dollars that's
about three times what the government
spends on national defense in a year and
for a program that big Parliament will
have to approve this is the largest
economic program in Canada's history so
I've asked the house leader and the
deputy minister to reach out to the
other parties about bringing back
Parliament this must be a Team Canada
effort I'm not understating when I say
business owners have been frantic to get
the details of this program I must have
heard from a dozen of them today their
biggest worry now is how
you stay in business until this wage
subsidy program kicks in and that could
be the middle of May Donna all right
David akin in Ottawa thank you
there's also new detail about the second
federal program being rolled out for
people no longer getting a paycheck
because of co vid 19 it's called the
Canada emergency response benefit
applications open on April 6
if you select direct deposit you should
we're told receive pay within three to
five days if you opt for a check in the
mail you should get it within ten days
the benefit will provide about two
thousand dollars a month to those who
have lost pay and will be available for
four months it is for those who do not
qualify for employment insurance
Canadians who are already receiving eaj
benefits will continue to receive them
and should not apply for the CRB and
here's a number two point 1 million
Canadians have applied for AI in the
last two weeks well we've talked about
how bad things are economically in
Alberta but Newfoundland and Labrador is
worse that province is so short of cash
the premier did something extraordinary
he wrote to the prime minister pleading
for help
warning the provinces out of time
finances were bad before this pandemic
but now is Ross Lord reports
Newfoundland and Labrador is on the
brink of disaster
this newfoundland oil refinery is
halting production due to kovat 19 boil
prices have plummeted sinking the market
for jet fuel and propane two of the
refineries main products take about five
days safely Newfoundland and Labrador
problems run much deeper its operating
deficit and overall debt were already
the highest per capita in Canada after
the pandemic hit finances became so
desperate premiered white-ball wrote to
the prime minister saying without
federal assistance the province would be
unable to pay its bills the letter said
we have no other recourse to raise the
necessary funds to maintain the
operations of government Bal added our
province has run out of time support
from the Bank of Canada allowed the
provincial government to hold an
emergency session of the how
of assembly and borrow two billion
dollars at the time the premier brushed
off the crisis can you cover payroll
without that loan we can there's no
question the problems was in a very
difficult situation we will be covering
payroll now his plea to the prime
minister is public it's really just
expressing were we as a province where I
would see it going and the need for the
federal government to look at
Newfoundland and Labrador as a unique
province Paul suggests his province will
need much more financial help after
Canada emerges from the pandemic Ross
Lord Global News in Quebec the premier
is so concerned about the pandemic he's
expanded the provinces travel
restrictions to four more regions today
there are now police checks on the
bridges that connect Ottawa and Gatineau
in Quebec it's to stop people
potentially infected with kovat 19 from
entering the province anyone trying to
enter Quebec who isn't an essential
worker may be forced to turn around more
than 270 million Americans have been
ordered to stay home and limit their
movements and Kentucky is now putting
ankle bracelets on some infected people
who refuse to stay home but the
restrictions are not nationwide the
rules vary and in some places it seems
it's too late confirmed cases keep
soaring there are more than two hundred
and eleven thousand in the US now a jump
of 22,000 today and more than 4,700
people are known to have died the real
number is certain to be higher because
we know people in places like New York
City are dying in their homes and even
in hospitals people are dying in such
numbers it's hard to keep an accurate
tally Jackson Proust Co reports they are
lives cut short by the kovat 19 pandemic
dr. James Goodrich a renowned
neurosurgeon who separated conjoined
twins 60 year-old Sharon Siler a
California woman with no underlying
health problems three members of the
konkey family in Ohio the grandmother of
New Yorker Robert Luger my grandmother
died alone
I think she died alone we didn't even
get to say bye to in hospitals across
the u.s. they're preparing for many more
grim days as doctors and nurses face
tough decisions about who they're able
to treat nearly everybody come to the
emergency department has this and we're
getting completely overloaded it's
predicted kovat 19 will kill at least
100,000 Americans in the coming months
with deaths and confirmed cases climbing
rapidly by the day that brutal reality
has forced even the most reluctant to
act Florida's governor who refused to
break up the party over spring break
bowed to pressure and issued a stay at
home order there are already 7,000 cases
in the state even though there's a lot
of places in Florida have very low
infection rates it makes sense to make
this move now
New York took more drastic steps closing
overcrowded playgrounds after families
refused to keep their distance
who else has to die for you to
understand you have a responsibility in
this nearly 85% of Americans are under
orders to only leave home for essential
reasons but for thousands of grieving
families it's simply too little too late
the US government's emergency stockpile
of masks gowns and gloves is dangerously
close to being depleted officials say it
was never meant to confront a 50-state
pandemic they're having a hard time
restocking it at the same time the US
government is said to be preparing an
order for 100,000 body bags Donna
Jackson Prosecco in Washington Thanks is
wearing a face mask in public worth it
coming up we'll dive into the debate
we know what works to protect us from
this virus staying physically distant
staying home and washing our hands but
what about wearing face masks in public
we know the medical grade ones the n95
masks are in short supply and they must
be saved for frontline workers but what
about more basic ones even homemade
masks as Mike Armstrong reports the
thinking on that is evolving it isn't
that there are a lot of masks in Austria
they're almost everywhere in fact as of
next week by law
they'll be mandatory in all grocery
stores as hidden agenda clear financial
sense on this probably should have been
introduced from the start this woman
says there are already two European
countries forcing people to wear masks
this is the recent swearing-in of the
new government in Slovakia in the
neighboring Czech Republic there's also
a movement to spread the idea globally
every one of masks for all I know they
maybe told you that masks wouldn't
protect you but they're studies proving
that even a homemade masks can be
partially protective partially any
protection is essential today
now the conclusions in the studies range
for masks being a last resort to
suggesting they should be a part of a
pandemic response in fact even homemade
masks worn by everyone could help slow
transmission several Asian countries
wear masks use is already common have
had more success controlling Kovan 19 in
South Korea they started they had their
first deaths about the same time as
Italy their deaths are now about a
hundred times less and they have the
magic recipe of four things testing
tracing quarantine and universal masks
query so far there is no appeal for the
Canadian public to wear masks
governments right now are focused on the
critical shortage of the n95 masks we do
need to protect medical masks for
medical professionals and other
frontline workers now there are
questions about whether the public would
use masks properly but the US Centers
for Disease Control is already
considering asking people to cover their
faces in public and at this Toronto
Hospital there's an appeal out for
homemade masks they want to distribute
them in the neighborhood to anyone who
comes within six feet of others the goal
isn't only to
protect the wearer but the people around
them as well I protect you you protected
me Mike Armstrong Global News Montreal
tracking kovat 19 still ahead it's
Canada keeping up with contact tracing
we keep talking about the number of
people tested for this virus but what's
just as important is something called
contact tracing the painstaking
detective like work that public health
workers do to trace every single person
someone with covin 19 came into contact
with those contacts need to be assessed
and isolated to break the chain of
transmission as Jeff sample explains
there is growing concern Canada is not
keeping up so I've never thought a
thousand years that I will get this
Amelio merit just got home from the
hospital The Vancouver actor has asthma
so when he started feeling sick last
month he assumed that's what it was and
then they start having pain in the chest
and then I try to breathe and I can on
March 21st he tested positive for kovat
19 his symptoms had first appeared on
March 13th and during that week in
between he says he'd mostly been at home
besides running a couple of errands BC
health officials asked for a list of all
of his contacts and then they told her
what I mean doing went to the gas
station and went to shop in so probably
she called everyone places I mean public
health officials did tell merits
housemates to self isolate but that gas
station he'd visited says they never
received any call and had no idea a
kovat 19 patient had been there we could
probably do more when it comes to
tracing the confirmed patients and
making sure that all those who are
isolated dr. Tina Park points to South
Korea which has received international
acclaim for flattening its curve
conducting more tests per capita than
any country when a case is confirmed
officials retrace their steps using
satellite credit card and smartphone
data then they send alerts to anyone who
may have had contact to appease those
privacy concerns this Montreal company
is developing an app that allows users
to decide whether to share their
location and receive alerts you would be
informed on your personal phone that
the course of the last would say 14 days
you've been in contact with someone who
has to sit positive of course that would
be completely anonymous the app should
be ready in a few weeks but it'll be up
to Canadians and their governments to
decide whether to use it to have simple
global news Toronto Prince Charles is
speaking out after recovering from coke
at 19 as we were learning this is a
strange frustrating you know from
distressing experience the 71 year old
is in good health he remains in Scotland
he only displayed mild symptoms and his
wife the Duchess of Cornwall has tested
negative for the virus
next the latest developments on finding
a treatment for Kovac 19:00 there is no
approved treatment for this virus but
labs all over the world are working to
develop some clinical trials are
underway and the American Federal Drug
Administration has approved the use of
two anti malarial drugs even though they
are unproven it's hoped the possible
benefits will outweigh the risks
Heather Urich's West on the race to find
a treatment hydroxychloroquine has been
used for years to protect people from
the devastating impacts of malaria
researchers believe it could help
protect against kovat 19 as well there's
some data to suggest that if you're
taking hydroxychloroquine and you're
exposed to the virus that the infection
won't take hold the evidence behind it
comes from the fact that it's able to
inhibit the replication of this virus in
a cell culture which means in a
laboratory but we don't have any
evidence that this works at all in
people which is why we need to do this
for patients across Manitoba Quebec and
Alberta are now being enrolled in the
international clinical trial one of
several studies currently underway in
this country as researchers search for a
treatment that works
we have no therapies for Kovach 19
specifically outside of high quality
hospital care and so that's the hope
that we all collaborate and coordinate
we learn as much as possible as fast as
possible the HIV drug Lapine of
renessa fear is another medication being
studied several provinces including BC
and Ontario have launched clinical
trials involving patients vulnerable to
the disease we're starting some trials
and care homes where if you are exposed
you get randomized to either a
medication or not and seeing if you get
infection in the end convalescent plasma
is being looked at carefully as well
this comes from the donated blood of
patients who have already recovered from
kovat 19 a hospital in Texas began the
first North American trial for this
therapy last weekend a Canadian trial
expected to involve 1000 patients will
likely start in about a month the
science is moving very quickly because
the virus is moving fast too researchers
hope to know soon what therapies work
and which ones don't
Heather Eric's best global news Calgary
and that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen we leave you
tonight with another reminder all of us
all over the world are in this together
this is Egypt the Great Pyramid of Giza
lit up with a message we can all get
behind stay home stay safe and thank you
to those keeping us safe thanks for
watching take care of yourselves
bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh